what's going on guys this is Rob we are
here with the fall of X X-Men red number
14 and the beginning of the Omega Level
mutant Civil War and this is amazing
okay so what this does like right off
the bat is it picks up with Robert
DeCosta showing up to storm on Mars and
telling her the X-Men have fallen it's
awesome right it's like from Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers when
Black Panther shows up to the Illuminati
and says like the Golden City is gone
wakanda has fallen right like it's just
this amazing moment right when he shows
up and he tells her like everybody's
dead right Jean Gray's dead Professor
Xavier I have no idea if he's dead I'm
pretty sure Cyclops is dead Captain
America might be dead lots and lots of
folks are dead storm had no idea this
was going on because she was dealing
with everything going on on Mars we'll
talk about that here in a second clear
it up for those of you guys who haven't
been following everything but when she
asked the question the five right the
mutants that we use to resurrect dead
mutants are they live and the response
to DeCosta is I think so I'm not 100
sure but the reality that we have to
accept here is whatever state they
happen to be in Resurrection is off the
table if we die we have to assume we
can't come back and so it's this crazy
moment right because one of the things
he talks about himself dealing with is
he kind of appears hungover but it's him
kind of dealing with the Fallout of when
orcas right the anti-mutant organization
basically forced Xavier of the X-Men to
use his telepathy to force all the
mutants on Earth off the planet right
like to force them through the gates
lest they all be destroyed on the spot
if anything it's kind of an act of Mercy
to a degree if you want to look at it
that way but that's when storm asked the
question who's responsible for this
right who did this and the response of
Dacosta is it's just some other dead
people they're named orcas now here's
the thing about storm under any normal
circumstance storms pretty chill right
she's pretty relaxed you know it's this
guy like hey storm what's going on oh
not a whole a lot you know just relaxing
doing my thing but when you piss her off
sun sun right to quote Ocean's 11 here
right she used to be civilized right
you'd attack storm she'd attack you back
done but in this day and age first
she'll kill you then she'll go to work
on you right this is it's it's amazing
how storm operates in this day and age I
absolutely love it and so were the
questions asked by everybody else who's
here what do we do the response of storm
is we go to war now before we actually
pick up what the war itself let's take a
step back do a little bit of explanation
here for those of you guys who are just
catching up with us right so it's
something that we've specified in the
past and it's a relatively new
development is that in Marvel Comics you
have the mutants on Earth we've known
about them for the longest time ever
since the X-Men were created then you
had mutants in another dimension called
orako eventually the mutants of that
Dimension left and then took off and
resided on Mars right literally Mars
became their home and they chose Mars
because they couldn't co-exist with
mutants on Earth because all these guys
from Morocco knew was war and conflict
and so during this time storm became a
kind of Emissary to a degree from Earth
on oracco so she could kind of bridge
the gap between the two groups Magneto
was there as well but he ultimately
ended up dying that took place during a
story called Judgment Day and in fact
that story was important because it saw
the near eradication of the entire
mutant population on Mars something like
99 of them were destroyed by a member of
the eternals so it was really cool when
the whole thing popped off but what we
also ended up seeing taking place is
that apocalypse who's a member of the
X-men group his wife former wife
whatever you want to call her had left
the dimension of Oracle and then shown
up on Mars and seized control and that's
the basis behind this Civil War it's the
rift that was created between the forces
of Genesis and the forces of storm
they're both vying for power and they're
both trying to seize control of this
place now picking up with the war itself
is exactly what you would expect the
fight between these two groups is
immense it's insane now where you're
looking at the sheer number of people
and you find yourself asking the
question okay if most of the mutant
population on Mars was destroyed where
did all these mutants come from a good
chunk of these are the forces of storm
but it was also Genesis who brought her
own forces from Morocco to take up
residence on Mars and to try to conquer
it so it's cool now one of the things to
remember here is that when it comes to
orocco itself not everybody there is a
mutant and in fact traditional
superheroes have temporarily taken up
residence there a really good example of
this is Richard Ryder Nova right like
he's just here as part of like the whole
Emissary to kind of inform of storm and
everybody on a Rocco what's happening
like out in space and that kind of a
thing right so it's really more his
political presence than anything else
but he's fighting alongside storm and
this war is intense because one of the
things to remember is that the forces of
a rocker right the forces of Genesis all
they've known is war their entire life
right so imagine from like the day you
were born I up until right now you've
had to just fight to survive you fight
for resources you fight people who want
to kill you because they simply just see
you as an enemy right like whatever the
case is it's nothing but survival of the
fittest it's like living in the south
side of Chicago right so literally storm
and her forces while they are powerful
don't quite know war in the same way
that the forces of Morocco do but do not
let that trick you into believing that
they are guaranteed to lose this fight
and in fact we'll talk about why they're
not guaranteed to lose here in a second
in the form of iska but the thing here
is that they're fighting for a cause
greater than their own because Genesis
believes that like giving people benefit
of the doubt kindness things like that
those are all forms of weakness right
the only thing that matters is that the
strongest deserve to survive that in a
lot of ways it's kind of her weakness
because she doesn't really see her
forces as lives worth saving she sees
him as Canon father right just throw
them in over and over and over again
right just kind of just non-stop fight
that's taking place constantly whereas
the forces of storm she cares about
their lives but they also Champion the
cause of what you would potentially call
goodness or kindness or something along
those lines so again it seems on the
surface almost a little kitty or a
little childish but the reality is once
you start getting into the deep
philosophical Rifts between these two
groups it quite literally boils down to
good versus evil right versus wrong but
it is all just a matter of perception
now what's so awesome about this is that
the forces of Genesis basically have the
skies right like what they're doing is
they're sending in what are called these
Omega Rockets basically these mutants
who are Omega Level that are like Sam
Guthrie from the X-Men right where they
can just kind of propel themselves in a
forward Direction but you also have
these characters operating with kind of
like unbreakable skin right they're
indestructible to a degree but one of
these Omega Rockets as he's flying
towards them gets shot in the head and
is quite literally killed by iska now
there's a reason why this girl is just
standing out here right because she says
you knew the rules all of you know the
rules my mountains are mine she's
totally out of the conflict and the
reason for this is because the power of
iska is one part ridiculous but awesome
at the same time the power of iska is
that she cannot lose right so like if
iska jumps into this conflict and then
she chooses aside say for example she
sides with storm the war's over it's
done it's over right like it's only a
matter of time before her side wins
that's just her power you can call it
bending luck in her favor whatever it
happens to be because Marvel doesn't
really Define exactly how her power
works and we could even go so far as to
argue the forces of Genesis once they
start to realize that iska's taking a
side of storm they would stop they would
give up right they wouldn't fight
anymore because they would know it would
be a moot point it'd be future they're
guaranteed to lose so better to give up
and survive than to fight and die now I
say that with a practical and with a
logical mindset in reality they would
just keep on fighting because they would
much rather die as Fighters than survive
as people who surrendered right that's
really their mindset and how they
function but the cool thing about this
is that with the forces of Genesis
basically having the sky this leads to
the arrival of storm now you may be
asking yourself where Storm been that's
actually explained to us in this amazing
monologue and what we're told here is
storm has been waylaid on the way to the
battle but now she had arrived and there
could be no more question of air
superiority for Aurora was the air and
at her command the sky itself fell to
its knees Aurora could have timed her
lightning to crush the armies of Genesis
instead she only blocked their way it
was a signal of her power but also of
her mercy she knew Genesis would scoff
call it weakness but weakness Mercy was
what the rebels fought for so it's one
of these things where like storm arrives
on the scene and the response of Genesis
4 sources is to retreat because the
reality here is that even Genesis being
as powerful as she is and even her
forces being as powerful as they are
they have enough sense not to mess with
storm you know what I mean like it's
just one of those things you just don't
do this is why I love how her character
is being handled in this day and age
because it's like a return to storm in
the 1980s back during the days when like
Chris Claremont was publishing her
stories it's just her as an absolute
demon of the second age you know what I
mean and so what happens is that in
response to the forces of Genesis
retreating everybody here knows the
war's not over right this is like a
battle right it's just a momentary
Victory but our forces will retreat they
will remarshall she'll build another
battle plan and they'll be back on the
offense again and this time they'll have
some kind of plan to basically counter a
storm and so one storm and our forces
Retreat back to our headquarters this is
where things get cool because what
happens is in this conversation they
kind of speculate where it is that
apocalypse is at now remember apocalypse
is back in Morocco he's in a whole
different dimension but he's forming his
own battle plans he has his own strategy
on what it is that he's trying to do and
they even go for us to say that he's not
the type to be kept in reserve and
that's an accurate statement because
apocalypse is immensely powerful so if
he shows up here in this battle and he
sides with storm you're suddenly going
to see the arrival of this mutant that
can grant himself any superhuman power
outside of reality warping he can grow
to 2 000 feet tall and the battle would
be over like that in the blink of an eye
the whole thing would be done he would
eradicate the forces of Genesis without
breaking a sweat and so where they kind
of muse on this for a second storm even
thinks like he may have been the first
to fall which is a ridiculous concept
but the response is either way the Mage
right referring to apocalypse is not the
true threat we haven't seen his children
yet either or the 100 now the 100 are
amazing right like the 100 swords
they're awesome the reason why is
because their leader has the ability to
heal people so literally him and his 100
could seemingly never die now what we
know in the events leading up to this is
that they're actually dead and for the
most part no one really seems to know
that that's the case hence the statement
we haven't seen him or his 100 but if
the 100 showed up in this battle Yeah
they would annihilate the forces of
Genesis as well right because they're
just that overpowered in their own
individual right and they're led by a
guy who can heal them and heal himself
right so literally they're soldiers that
just cannot be killed they can even be
brought back from the dead right if that
would blow your mind it's just one of
the crazy things about them but the
children of Apocalypse the horsemen
they're on a whole different level of
just death and destruction if they enter
this battle on the side of Genesis and
there's no one like apocalypse or the
100 to stand in their way it's game over
and Genesis takes the war right so again
it could go either way depending on any
one of of these guys and that's why they
say when they arrive any one of these
apocalypse the 100 the children right
the horsemen when they arrive that's
when the war starts that's when we
really start fighting for our lives
that's when it all picks up and so again
it does to a degree fill the forces of
storm and even herself with a bit of
trepidation but it's not enough to give
up and quit and so what storm says is
she says up until now Genesis has
avoided attacks by sea her hold on
sobinar might be weaker than we think
but with her ground attacks consistently
beaten back it's her only option when
she's ready she'll send everything she
has and that's when you get this comment
that comes out of nowhere where this guy
says then so be it if they try to take
us here we'll hold them fast and finish
what they began a rocky have history
with Siege Warfare and our histories in
our blood the person who's talking is
fisher king why does this matter because
when this guy was first presented to us
he had no powers but there's no
conceivable way that a guy with no
powers survived in a dimension filled
with some of the most powerful mutants
in existence all of whom were fighting
for their very survival what this guy's
powers are I'm not entirely sure but I
can guarantee you this dude is op
there's no way he's not but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on fall of X make sure you click this
link to our playlist which also includes
Judgment Day so you can get current on
everything that's happening and I will
catch you all later peace